es ist die wichtigste wahl der welt sind
die heißeste phase hat begonnen
um mitternacht machte das erste
wahllokal in new hampshire auf und an
der ostküste geht es jetzt los um 14 uhr
öffnen die ersten wahllokale und alles
dreht sich um die frage wer wird künftig
an diesem schreibtisch sitzen würde es
weiter donald trump sein der 45
präsident der vereinigten staaten oder
joe biden der mann der ihn heute nacht
herausfordert sie verpassen nichts ab 18
uhr 30 sind wir bei bild live für sie da
mit unseren kollegen teilweise und nele
würzbach berichten wir zwölf stunden
lang live und unsere reporter sind im
ganzen land in den usa unterwegs und
berichten von dort hallo aus arizona wir
sind in den vergangenen drei wochen quer
durch die usa gereist waren in florida
in new york in arizona in nevada in
kalifornien im pennsylvania aber für die
wahl sind wir hier nach arizona
zurückgekehrt warum
nirgendwo haben wir so begeisterte trump
unterstützer kennengelernt wie hier und
diese menschen wollen wir euch den
ganzen tag über genauer erklären und vor
allem begleiten und dann droht hier im
wüstenstaat ein kleines politisches
erdbeben joe biden liegt in den umfragen
vorne
und das wäre dann zum ersten mal seit
jahrzehnten dass arizona ein blauer
staat wird und am ende womöglich
präsident trump über genau arizona
stolpert das alles behalten wir genau im
blick den ganzen tag und die nacht über
bei bild live hallo mein name ist carina
mass bauer und ich bin chefreporterin
bei bild und für bild bereits seit zwei
wochen in den usa unterwegs
nun sind wir zurück in washington dc
denn am dritten november blickt die welt
auf die usa und dort natürlich vor allem
auf die hauptstadt
ich werde den ganzen wahltag hier in
washington dc unterwegs sein
an den unterschiedlichsten orten und mit
verschiedenen gesprächspartnern und
natürlich möchte ich sie mitnehmen auf
diese spannende reise an diesem
historischen tag durch den district of
columbia
hier ist herbert bauernebel wir sind
hier in wilmington delaware das ist die
heimatstadt von joe biden dem eigentlich
favoriten bei dieser großen
amerikanischen war hier in wilmington
soll auch wenn es nach plan geht die
siegesfeier stattfinden für joe biden
sollte er tatsächlich gewinnen und wir
sind hier den ganzen wahltag und den
wahlabend um hier vor ort zu berichten
aus wilmington der heimatstadt von job
schon in wenigen stunden wird sich
entscheiden muss donald trump seine
privaten fotos aus dem oval office mit
nach hause nehmen
herr ausräumen die fotos und sein vater
seiner familie seiner frau und das ist
glaube ich sogar kleine ivanka darum
geht es aber natürlich geht es auch
darum wer wird künftig der mächtigste
mann der welt ja hier in diesen räumen
wird sich einiges ab spielen heute nacht
diese vorhänge übrigens schön goldner
die hat donald trump extra austauschen
lassen sie hingen schon bei b clinton
obama hatte noch dunkelrote aber wir
wissen trump setzt auf gold ja hier
unter den wachsamen augen von abraham
lincoln dem ersten republikanischen
präsidenten aber auch unter den
wachsamen augen von benjamin franklin
und andrew jackson wird sich hier heute
nacht in dieser großen weihnacht einiges
abspielen
wir haben das oval office das wichtigste
büro der welt für sie nachempfunden und
wir freuen uns heute abend auf wichtige
gäste aus politik wirtschaft und
gesellschaft sie verpassen nichts
kein faktum keine neue entwicklung
keinen tweet ab 1830 geht's los wir sind
zwölf stunden für sie live da wir freuen
uns auf sie wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren